all right so listen some of you know who
John Campbell is some of you don't John
Campbell is a PhD in nursing who has a
YouTube channel that blew up during the
coveted pandemic and he would provide a
mix of sensible information and analyzes
but he would also dabble in anti-vaxx
and some sort of stranger stuff that he
would flirt with and people would write
to me and they would say David Dr John
Campbell is a doctor who knows about all
this stuff why why aren't you in
lockstep with him and you know when when
we talk about Dr Jill Biden
she has a PhD in education there's no
possibility that anybody thinks Jill
Biden's a medical doctor right but not a
medical doctor PhD in education the
difficulty with Dr John Campbell is that
he is talking about medicine he's
talking about medications and vaccines
and treatments and pandemics he has a
PHD in nursing specializing in online
teaching
okay now this doesn't mean that
everything John Campbell says is wrong
but so many people see someone called Dr
John Campbell talking about medicine and
they assume you're talking about a
medical doctor it's not that a PhD in
nursing is worthless it's just that he's
not a medical doctor and during the
pandemic people would email me email me
email me saying listen to this doctor
and what he's saying okay
he now is feigning outrage that a new
mRNA flu vaccine
is doing phase one trials with only 50
people
except that's what phase one trials are
and he has even said that without
feigning outrage in the past so this is
another example
creating fear generating uncertainty
firing people up let's listen here he is
talking about the clinical trials of the
MRNA flu vaccine uh the number involved
up to 50 healthy volunteers 18 through
to
49 years of age
so this is direct from their website
this is not me this is not me having a
joke here
not a joke guys they really have only 50
people claiming the National Institutes
of Health in the United States are
claiming
that
by testing 50 volunteers healthy 18
through to 49
they can assess the safety of this
vaccine okay
how how dare are they now if you do any
research you find that phase one
clinical trials start with 20 to 80
people and you only need to look at his
own prior statements about phase one
clinical trials to realize that the
feigned outrage is fake here is Dr John
Campbell in February of 2020 this is
great video compiled by the bad stats
Twitter Channel they do a really good
job
where he says this is typical vaccine
and the
China vaccine are now being tested for
safety in animals
now the next stage after this in early
spring will be phase one human trials
now in phase one clinical trials the
drug or the vaccine in this case is
given to a relatively small amount of
healthy volunteers
totally normal in phase one clinical
trials it's given to a small number of
healthy volunteers August of 2022 same
thing now uh
that's the molecule there apparently
right phase one trial has been done on
healthy volunteers already so this is in
way on in its way next few months report
from 42 patients
and if that's a good quality now no no
problem there okay so listen this is not
about uh to be honest I haven't seen any
of John Campbell's content for a long
time now it's not about going after him
uh as a bad person or whatever what I
can tell you is the following
um there's no reason to now start
stoking skepticism about the MRNA flu
vaccine because the phase one trial has
50 people that's normal John Campbell
has on numerous occasions told us phase
one trials have a small number of people
here's one with 42 people no totally
non-reactive and now he feigns outrage
that this is it's not a joke folks
they're really assessing this based on
50 people that's how a phase one trial
works so you know again just understand
what your sources are Google simple
things it would take one second to say
how many people are normally in a phase
one clinical trial there is nothing to
be outraged about I very much look
forward to the data about this mRNA flu
vaccine maybe we will get ourselves a
flu vaccine that is more effective than
the ones that have sometimes floated
around over the last few years which
sometimes are only 20 to 40 effective
sometimes it's more but sometimes it's
only 20 to 40 percent I would love a
more effective flu vaccine that should
be the focus